ثروات اغنياء العالم في انخفاض استنتاج
مثير للدهشه نشره تقرير حديث لفوردس اظهر
ان العام الفائت وحده شهد تراجعا في ثروات
عدد من اصحاب المليارات في العالم ففي عام
2022 بلغت قيمه ثروه اغنياء العالم مجتمعه
12 تريليونا و700 مليار دولار لكنها
انخفضت بمقدار 500 مليار دولار هذا العام
وخرج على اثرها ثمانيه وعشرون مليارديرا
من القائمه رجل الاعمال الامريكي كان
الاكثر تضررا بعد هبوط اسهم امازون
بثمانيه وثلاثين بالمئه ما تسبب بخسارته
سبعه وخمسين مليار دولار كما شهدت القائمه
تراجع ايلون ماسك للمركز الثاني بعد صفقه
استحواذه على تطبيق تويتر وتاثيرها السلبي
على اسهم شركه تسلا فيما تربع الفرنسي
برناود ارنو على عشر الاغنياء ليكون
الفرنسيه الاول في التاريخ الذي يحتل هذا
المركز
لكن رغم ذلك فان امريكا لا تزال تملك
735 غنيا وهو العدد الاكبر في العالم
بمجموع ثروات يصل الى اربعه تريليونات
ونصف التريليون دولار